Not getting enough sleep
won't just make you cranky.
It could kill you.
The United Nations even
considers sleep deprivation
a form of torture.
And the longer it lasts,
the worse it'll get.
Losing sleep affects people differently,
but generally the effects
increase as the hours do.
Just 48 hours without sleep is considered
extreme sleep deprivation,
but you'll probably get weird before then.
After 18 hours with no sleep,
you might feel a little drunk.
Staying awake that long is equivalent
to having a blood
alcohol content of 0.05%,
which is what you get
with three or four drinks
in the span of two hours.
24 sleepless hours,
that BAC comparison jumps to 0.1%,
higher than the legal
driving limit in every state.
You might feel foggy, less
alert, or uncoordinated,
almost like you're wearing
sleepy beer goggles,
including double or blurry vision.
That's because sleep
deprivation slows down
our brain cells' ability
to talk to each other.
So if you actually are drinking alcohol,
drowsiness can increase its effects.
And while caffeine could make you feel
more alert for several hours,
it'll only work up to a certain point.
By a day and a half,
this could all get worse and then some.
Your chances of getting
sick are higher than usual
because your body can't
fight like it normally can,
and around this time, your
brain and body get so tired
that you start experiencing microsleeps,
tiny periods of sleep,
maybe around 30 seconds,
that you might not even notice.
Definitely annoying and even dangerous
if you're doing something
like driving a car.
And then there's the
potential for hallucinations.
Visual distortions are most common.
Your water bottle grows to twice its size
or moves around the room.
But you could also experience sensational
or auditory hallucinations,
things like feeling
someone who's not there
tap you on the shoulder or
hearing your name being called.
[ghostly voice whispering inaudibly]
Once you hit 48 hours,
it's literal torture,
which is why
extreme-sleep-deprivation studies
are now prohibited by
law in most countries.
Two days without sleep can cause you
to start losing your grip on reality.
Hallucinations worsen,
and you might even
undergo depersonalization.
That's the feeling that
reality is slipping away,
which may or may not include
an out-of-body experience.
Tack on extreme anxiety,
irritability, stress, and fatigue,
and it's no wonder the UN doesn't allow
this kind of deprivation.
After 72 hours, you're
not gonna be able to think
about anything but hitting the hay.
Forget about doing simple tasks.
Things like getting
dressed or finding a snack
could feel overwhelming,
partially from fatigue
and partially because your
ability to regulate emotions
is basically out the window.
Your hallucinations
could get more complex,
creating fully formed images
like a person, or a bear,
or maybe a car you shouldn't drive.
And in at least four
historical sleep studies,
participants reported
shared hallucinations,
namely something called
the hat phenomenon,
which is basically a feeling
of pressure around your head
as if you're wearing a hat.
All of this opens the door for paranoia,
depression, and delusions.
Which brings us to 96 hours
or more with no sleep.
Say bye-bye to reality, folks.
More and worse hallucinations and paranoia
could lead to sleep-deprivation psychosis,
a total snap from the real world.
Historically, women
accused of being witches
were kept awake long enough
to trigger this psychosis.
Judges considered their visions
and ramblings confessions,
leading to the women's convictions.
Now, the fifth day is sometimes
called the turning point.
This is the danger zone.
Your mental health takes a sharp decline,
cementing your delusions
as your new reality.
Eventually, your brain will
stop functioning properly
in a way that could lead to organ failure
and, in rare cases, death.
Luckily, recovering from sleep deprivation
can be as simple as catching up on sleep,
but if you're sleep deprived regularly,
you're looking at long-term effects
like weight gain, acne, headaches,
and high blood pressure,
among other things.
And it can take weeks
to get back on track.
According to one study,
you need four days to recover
from losing a single hour of sleep.
Try getting to bed early
instead of sleeping in late,
or, better yet, avoid the
recovery period entirely
by getting seven to eight
hours of sleep every night
in the first place.